is a tense environment for U.N
peacekeepers in Mali they've been
ordered to close their mission known as
manusma by the end of the year that
leaves just four months to get 12 500
troops and all their military hardware
out of the country and increasingly as
they attempt to do so they're being
attacked just last week the head of U.N
peacekeeping operations met with Molly's
transitional authorities to work out the
details of the drawdown
our colleagues in the mission are
working tirelessly to mitigate risks
however I haven't forgotten that some
have been injured in recent weeks the
situation presents both logistical and
security challenges
it was Malian authorities who insisted
the UN leave they expected yvegni
pregosian's Wagner group to help fill
the void and back government troops in
their fight against groups linked to
isil and al-Qaeda in the region but even
before pagosians reported death security
analysts say fighting between those
groups was on the rise also increasing
human rights violations by government
troops and civilian deaths Wasim Nasser
is a security analyst Wagner came in
human rights abuses it fueled Jihadi
groups and by Wagner going in the French
went out and now the munisma is going
out creating a huge a huge uh void
actually and permitting those groups to
act more freely drawing down the mission
in Mali by the end of the year was never
going to be easy by comparison the UN
took three years to withdraw a force
half its size from Darfur Sudan now
growing instability in the Sahel region
cast out on the un's ability to make
that timeline
a new report by the U.N Secretary
General notes the recent coup in Niger a
Transit hub for U.N operations will make
the drawdown extremely challenging and
require more than the 590 million
dollars budgeted Niger is one of the
routes for repatriating uh personnel and
equipment and obviously when a country's
borders are shut down
um we can't do that so alternate rounds
will probably need to be found the UN
says it will only hand bases over to
civilian authorities and it will
continue to have a presence in Mali to
liquidate remaining assets even after
its troops are gone Kristin salumi Al
Jazeera the United Nations
foreign make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
Jazeera